an arrest report is laying out the
moments leading up to a grisly crash
that claimed the lives of two little
girls alcohol and lack of child car
seats played a major role those closest
to the toddlers torn up over a loss they
feel could have been prevented Madison
Kimbrough live near Lone Mountain and
Clayton after talking with the girl's
father
two girls the two toddlers and tonight
we've obtained more details into the
aftermath of the crash
North Las Vegas Police releasing the
arrest report in the crash that killed
two young girls just over a week ago in
the report it states that the children's
Aunt Kalia Manning was allegedly driving
drunk with the children's Mother
raynisha Washington knowingly riding
along in the passenger seat Tavon Wilmer
the girl's father saying this to 8 news
now qbq is safe
don't drink and drive neither of the
toddlers two-year-old Rosemarie and
three-year-old Taylor Wilmer were in
proper car seats at the time as reports
show that Washington claimed that she
had recently sold them rosemarie's
babysitter having this to say it's
Saturday night's vigil I took care of
her on numerous occasions myself me and
my mother took turns taking care of her
and it was really heart crunching just
hearing and seeing what took place in
the report police stating that when they
approached the car Rose Marie's body was
found outside while Taylor's Body was
lying inside the children's Aunt
according to the report was found
conscious and shaking the children's
Mother raynisha Washington who was
unconscious in the passenger seat and
police say a strong odor of alcohol
could be smelled from the driver's area
as Manning's eyes were bloodshot Manning
suffered a ruptured spleen and internal
bleeding and Washington suffers a
ruptured bladder spinal and hip injuries
a broken femur and internal bleeding the
children's father telling eight news now
that he does not fault Washington or
Manning for what happened I never
judge you for what you did I know you
loved our kids
Washington the toddler's mother stating
that she witnessed her friend and sister
finish an entire bottle of tequila
before the crash now when we the police
questioned Manning about how much
alcohol that she consumed she said that
she had two shots and that she thought
she was fine reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now
we can also tell you tonight Manning the
driver facing several charges including
three counts of DUI resulting in death
two counts of child neglect two counts
of operating a vehicle without child
safety restraints meantime the child's
mother is facing child abuse and neglect
charges they're both expected in court
tomorrow